Bringing back dial up: The Internet over SMS
Alexandra Sunderland
KATIE: Hello. How were the snacks? Were they
good? Yeah. Oh, my gosh, are those chocolate
cupcakes with like mousse? I wanted to eat
probably 20 of those. But I didn't because
I wanted to make sure that everyone else got
one too. So, if you had a chocolate little
cupcake, you can thankme for exercising
restraint. All right. So, our next speaker
is Alexandra Sunderland. She's an engineer
at fellow.app. But the most interesting and
amazing thing about her and I am so jealous
certify she sews her own clothing. So, the
dress she is wearing on stage far outshines
my dress that has code on it because she designed
and sewed it herself and it even has a little
secret pocket on the pack for her to put her
like mic pack. Which is genius. And I think
she needs to start, like, I don't know. She
needs to open up an Etsy store to start selling
them women speakers everywhere. All right.
She's going to talk to us about bringing back
dial up in the Internet over SMS. Give it
up for Alexandra.
[ Applause ]
ALEXANDRA: Hi, everyone. I'm Alexandra. I
work at fellow.app. We're building a product
that acts as a manager's copilot. Helps you
organize your one on ones, organize feedback,
action in meetings and track action items.
If that's interesting, talk to me or check
out fell.app. But I want to talk about a completely
different project I have been working on in
my spare time. This is an app that I built
for my phone that lets you access the Internet
in a real browser without having to have a
data or Wi Fi connection. It transfers it
over SMS. To give you a preview, on the left,
a screenshot of the app where you are going
to enter the URL for the website. And on the
right side, there's a website for my default
messaging application that shows the communication
going on behind the scenes between phone and
the server. Why on Earth would I make something
like this when we have access to free Wi Fi
and data connections all over the world. I
come from a country where I get 2 gigabytes
of data every month for $80 and the prices
for Internet are so expensive in this country
that three quarters of a million people are
still using dial up Internet connections in
their home. I come from Canada.
[ Laughter ]
So, the data prices are so expensive just
when I'm at home in my own country. It's whenever
I'm traveling I have to pay an arm and a leg
just to be able to browse the Internet. To
be here right now, I'm paying $100 just to
get access to 1 gigabyte of data. And this
is kind of an issue for me because I really,
really love to travel. And I spend a lot of
time in places like Paris, the streets look
like this, they're all over the place. I'm
extremely directionally impaired. I get lost
in New York City where the streets are in
a grid and numbered. And I end up in these
situations in places like Paris. And I walk
in one direction and I have to take the sub
quay to get back to where I was originally
trying to go. I could download an offline
map and use that to walk around. But when
I want to take the subway, that requires up
to date real time information and I can't
get that online. And so, I decided to do something
about this. And one of the first things that
I notice when had I started trying to solve
this problem is that my phone plan has unlimited
SMS in most countries or very, very cheap
messaging. So, originally a couple years ago
when I started this, the big thing at the
time was building chat bots. And a lot of
companies started building these interfaces
through like Facebook messenger or whatever.
So, I decided that because I have unlimited
SMS, I'll build a chat bot. And the way that
it worked was I would be able to send a message,
how do I get from here to there. That message
was sent to the server, have unlimited access
to the Internet, you could use the Google
API and get it back to me. I could use this
in France for 15 cents and get all the directions
I needed.
I used this a lot. And I could store address
books and say, how do I get home? You could
say I want to get there at 4 p.m. It would
do that for you but, it was so useful that
I kind of got addicted to having access to
the Internet so I would want to look up a
translation of a word. And build an API integration
for that. Or look up a rating for a restaurant
I was next to and I built an API integration
for that. And I started spending so much time
building these one off integrations. I decided,
this is kind of silly. I shouldn't be doing
this. I should just build a browser instead.
And that is what we're going to go other now.
There are two parts to this project. That's
the Android app on one side and the Node.js
server on the other. The app I built in Android
because I figured this is something I'm going
to use, so, screw iPhones.
[ Laughter ]
I did it in Java and not Kotlin because I
was completely new to building phone apps.
I had never worked with the SMS API and there's
a lot more on StackOverflow about SMS with
Java. I'm going with that because of the community
around it. The server I built in Node.js because
I thought it would be fun to put it on the
server where it does not belong to create
a browser where it's not supposed to be. For
communication between these two parts, I used
Twilio. Twilio is a really great company with
a lot of services around communication and
messaging. The part that I used here is something
that lets me forward SMS to a server. So,
what I've done is I bought a number on Twilio
and phone number every message that I send
to that phone number will be sent as a post
request with a bunch of information about
the message to my server. To set up the limitations
that I had to deal with for this project,
so, I want to transfer an entire web page
over SMS to my phone. But SMS only allows
for 160 characters at a time which is about
the size of a Tweet. So, it kind of is discouraging
already to havetransfer a whole bunch of
messages this way. And even more so, if you
look at a page that's very simple like Google,
all we think about when we look at this page
is the input and the button and maybe the
word Google. But when you actually look at
source of this page, this is a quarter million
characters in HTML. So, if we were to break
this up into messages and send this over without
doing anything to it, it would take 1300 SMS
to get there. And this would cost $10 in Twilio
fee alone which is a lot more than I was willing
to pay. But when we think about the website
and the functionality behind it, it's the
form, the word, the input, the button and
it's very, very small and fits into a single
SMS. And so, when I was going about this,
I decided that any web page I have, I'm gonna
want to make a programmatic way to get it
down from this big bulky thing to a tiny thing
that just represents the interactions that
I want to have with it. We're going to walk
through the life cycle of requesting a website
and then actually getting around to rendering
it. Right off the bat, when we want to the
request a URL, we end up with a pretty big
limitation. URLs, the spec says that a URL
can be 2,000 characters in length which could
end up taking 13 whole SMS., when we start
off by being an SMS, we chop off the HTTPS,
WWW, it's assumed every website has that anyway.
It's going to take up space in the message.
The browser isn't going to support tracking
information or fancy JavaScript stuff. So,
anything that follows after the real part
of the URL is something we can just get rid
of. So, if we have a URL like this, we can
just use the yellow part that's highlighted
and send that over SMS. And to do that, Android
has this very, very simple SMS manager API
which is just lines nine and ten here. This
took many hours of StackOverflowing to figure
out. It was very difficult. But really all
you have to do is get permissions to send,
receive and read SMS. And then initialize
the SMS manager API, specify the phone number
you want to send the message to, specify the
body of the message, and then it sends it
off for you and takes care of everything.
So, then this message is sent to the Twilio
number that I own. And Twilio takes that and
turns it into this very, very big JSON blob
with a whole bunch of information. And I've
highlighted the parts that are important here.
So, at first we have the body which is just
the URL that we're requesting. The two number,
which is the number that I have. And the from
number, which is the number that we're gonna
want to send the data back to at the end.
So, this is sent to the server. Which then
has to do a lot of processing. So, I spend
a lot of time working on React components
which, when you look at them on their own,
are very, very small, tiny things and I kind
of forget sometimes just how big our websites
end up being. So, I accidently press new page
source pretty often when I mean inspect element
and I see this wall of HTML that looks horrible
and it's impossible to understand looking
tat like this. And this is the HTML that the
server has to deal with when it's trying to
figure out how to send this over SMS. But
there are a lot of things in this HTML that
we know we can get rid of right off the bat.
Like, we aren't gonna support JavaScript.
We can get rid of all that code. We're not
going to support CSS, we can get rid of all
style tags. We're not gonna support thing
like images. So, the first thing that happens
to get that HTML is on the Node.js server,
we're using express to set up this web application.
We're going to start by grabbing that URL
from the text message. Pre pending HTTPS.
It's a real URL. Just getting the HTML for
that page and then loading that into a library
called Churio. It's like JQuery for the server.
And all we're gonna use that for is to get
the body for the page so we have a much smaller
subset of code to dealwith. The next thing
we're gonna do is use this library, sanitize
HTML. And this is a library this lets you
decide what tags you want, what attribute
on those tags you want, and then you pass
it some HTML and it will filter it down to
what you want it to be. So, I figured in this
simple browser, the only tags I care about
other than text are anchor tags, input elements
and forms. That lets you access the rest of
the Internet and really interact with the
text based website. And on those tabs, we
care about the value, the type, the name.
And anything that's class or data. Like, we
can get rid of. Because we don't have CSS,
so, allowing class tags would or class attributes
would take up quite a bit of space that we
don't really have the ability to use. The
last part of sanitized HTML here is this exclusive
filter. And that's something that lets you
set up a function of the tags and attributes.
So, for example, we might want to hide all
hidden inputs because we're not going to be
able to see them. So, it's kind of wasted
space. And we get rid of privacy policies
in terms and conditions because we're not
going to click on them. There's no point in
setting them. At this point we have a lot
of like, a lot of tags and a couple of different
HTML tags here and there. And so, we have
to start compressing the English text. And
the logical thing to do at this point is to
run this through Gzip and send that. But this
is not a logical problem. So, the first way
that I decided to compress the text is by
doing character replacements for really common
words. So, the word the and are extremely
common in English. And there are a lot of
letters in English that aren't used. Like
everything except for A and I. And so, what
I decided to do is replace these common words
with a single letter variations. So the becomes
T and becomes ampersand and so on and so forth.
And this is a really easy compression to decompress
on the Android side. If we see a single later
on its own that's not A or I, it's clearly
that other word. We can do this for the 24
letters that don't mean anything. And then
we can do the combinations of two letters
that don't mean anything and we can compress
a lot of words in the end this way. To do
that, all we have to do is set up this mapping
of long word to short word. And then just
go through that mapping and do a replace all.
We don't care about the structure of the HTML
at this point. It's probably going to be okay.
If you're visiting a website like Wikipedia,
there are probably a lot of really big words
that don't need to be that big. So, penitentiary
means the same as jail, a four letter word.
We can find the long words, find synonyms
for them that are really short and replace
those. This is not a reversible compression.
[ Laughter ]
So, on the Android side, you could take all
the very short words and find the longest
possible synonyms for them. But it's you're
going to get some interesting results. The
next way that we're gonna start compressing
things is by replacing links. So, when I'm
on my computer, I have the proper behavior
of hovering over a link before I click it,
seeing that it's a good trustworthy link and
then clicking on it. When I'm on my phone,
I just click on the link and I don't care
where it goes. And I decided I should take
advantage of that behavior. So, what I do
here is let's say I have a link in real HTML
that goes to fellow.app. What I can do is
replace that link with a three character long
random string. Send that over to the browser
or the app. And then when I click on the app,
that three that thing is sent back to the
server. And the server knows, this isn't a
real URL. I should figure out what it's supposed
to be and get the HTML for that link. And
this saves a lot of space on a lot of websites.
Because websites are covered with links. And
sometimes the words that are link ready really,
really short. But the URLs tend to be extremely
long. So, this saves a lot of space. And the
way that I do this is by using Redis, which
is a in memory key value data store. So, for
every URL that's encountered in the HTML,
it's passed to this URL shortener function.
And it generates the random string and then
is sets the value in Redis as the phone number_short
URL. Sorry, that's the key. And then the value
is the real URL. And this so, setting it
"phone number first reduces the chances of
there being collisions. But there still is
the chance that you'll get the same URL stored
under the same the same short link. But
that's okay. It's all gonna be our own URL.
So, it's not a big deal. Okay. So, the last
way of compressing the HTML is by using Greek
characters.
[ Laughter ]
One of the great things about the SMS character
set is that it allows for Greek characters.
And most of the websites that I visit, at
least, do not have Greek characters on them.
And so, I decided to take advantage of that.
Now, because we have such a small subset of
HTML tags and attributes, I figured there's
this way of mapping all of these combinations
to different characters. So, I color coded
the original version and the shortened version
here. So, like the bracket input is that first
one, type equals quotation mark is the second
one. And it might look a bit odd that the
words are combined with the different like
equals and quotation marks. But we know that
type is always going to be followed by an
equals and then a quotation mark. And so,
we can do this because we have enough characters
in the Greek letters to do this explicit mapping.
This shortens can quite a bit. One of the
issues with SMS is that it does not have guaranteed
delivery or a guarantee that it will arrive
in the same order that it's sent. So, we might
end up with the situation where we have six
messages sent. Two of them never make it and
then the four that do arrive completely out
of order. I decided to ignore the fact that
some SMS might not make it. In order to recover
from that kind of issue it would require building
out an entire networking system. That was
a bit above what I wanted to do with this.
Because if some of the messages don't arrive,
you can just reload the page and it's not
going to be a huge issue. But for the arriving
out of order issue, that's quite a big thing
with my phone. What I've done here, is if
these three messages make up the entirety
of the HTML to be sent out. We're going to
prefix them with met data, we can see that
they are there. And we wait for a total of
three. And once that arrives, we know the
order to place them in to get valid HTML.
To do this, Twilio has a great Node.js library.
All we have to do is say messages.create and
then specify the body of the message, who
the message is from, and then the number that
it's going to which is something that was
sent in the post request earlier on. So, now
this is being sent back to the phone. And
the way we receive it is through something
on Android called broadcast receiver. And
broadcast receiver is something that you can
set up to listen out for different signals,
for events that happen within the phone. Here
I have one set up for listening for a coming
SMS. And what this does is it just waits for
all the SMS not shown here, very condensed.
But waits for the SMS and sends it off to
an activities and Android's version of a view.
So, once we have all the SMS, we've concatenated
them together, we have to start by reversing
the Greek letter conversion so that we have
some real HTML to deal with. Reverse the shortened
English words. Not the thesaurus way, just
the single letter shortening. We're going
to add some spaces between the closing and
opening tags just to add a little bit of visual
interest to the page because there's no CSS,
there's nothing. We got to make it a little
bit more readable. And then we're going to
load it in a web view. So, if you've ever
opened Slack and clicked on a link and it
opens Chrome within Slack, they're using a
web view component. So, a web view is Chrome
within an app. And you can either send it
a URL to open, or Amazingly, you can send
it some HTML to open which was the best discovery
in the world. When I was building this, I
thought I was going to have to build my own
rendering engine. And I almost stopped. And
this is what it looks like. So, on the right
side we have the actual message that was sent
to transfer all of Google.ca. And on the left
we have the rendering in the app of that web
page. So, this
[ Applause ]
This is pretty on point with what Google looked
like 15 years ago. So, it's not too bad. When
I started this out, I had a goal of getting
this web page down to 10 SMS. I thought that
would be a completely unattainable amazing
thing to do. It was starting off 1300. And
I got it down to three SMS for the whole page.
So, once I did that, I was really interested
because this project is named dial up, I was
curious to see, how fast is this compared
to actual dial up? On my phone on a good day
using a regular browser, it takes 2 seconds
to load the page. On dial up a few years ago,
45 seconds. And using this method over SMS,
it takes 10 seconds. Which when it's the only
way you have of accessing the Internet, that's
not long at all. SMS is not secure at all.
[ Laughter ]
SMS has the capability of being intercepted,
it's not encrypted. It's yeah. It's not
secure. So, this is not something that should
be used for password related, anything credit
card related. Anything like that. So, one
of the things that I do is get rid of sign
in links, if we're not going to click on them
anyways, why use the space. Because it's no
cookies, on the other hand, this is more secure
than other browsers. One of the ways that
this project could have been quite a bit easier
is using MMS instead of SMS. That costs a
fraction of a cent more and it supports quite
a bit more data. But just like Gzip, that
is just not a fun solution. There are a lot
of things that could be done with this project.
So.
, one of the we could do thing like web
sockets. Phones and SMS are by nature bidirectional
communication. They could send something to
the phone when there's communication, nothing
fancy there. And AJAX, if I visit Tweeter
a lot, I could store that on my phone ahead
of time and use these requests to get only
the contents of Tweets or the content that
really changes. We could use add support for
JavaScript. Or my favorite one is support
for real dial up. So, through the Android
API you can also make voice calls. And I thought
it would be really cool if instead of doing
SMS, if it did real dial up where you initiate
a phone call, the server and phone go back
and forth for a couple seconds and then all
the data far website is transferred that way.
So, it would probably only take a couple seconds
and might end up being cheaper and more reliable
than SMS. That would be super cool. Going
backwards. So, I did not know about travel
SIM cards when I started this project.
[ Laughter ]
I found about these a few months ago. If you
don't know, you can get a travel SIM card
for about $20 or $30 and it gives you access
to about 20 gigabytes of data in whatever
country you're traveling to. In comparison,
I pay $80 for 2 gigs. This is a great solution
and this is what I do now.
[ Laughter ]
If you want to get in touch with me or check
out more about the project, here's my website
and Twitter. Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
KATIE: Wow, okay. I take it back. Sewing her
own clothes is no longer the most impressive
thing that Alexandra has on her resume. That
was so good and so creative and inspiring.
And I want to learn more about how your brain
works how you came up with this idea at all.
It's so original. Up next we have Daniel Cousineau
is going to be giving us a really I hope
it's going to be mind blowing. I'm expecting
lots of explosions and lazars. Time is a social
construct and I'm really, really interested
to learn more about what he means by that.
Anyways, we'll be back here at 5:15. So, in
about 20 minutes. So, we will see you then.